- [Instructor] In this video
we're going to go through
a few examples of setting up some problems
with constant acceleration.
We're not going to solve them,
we're just going to look at what we know
and what the question is asking for
and then identify which one
of these equations over here
will be the most useful
for helping us solve it.
So before we jump into the examples,
I wanna say that it is very important to
understand where these equations come from
to really develop a
strong understanding of
position and velocity
and acceleration and time
and how they're all
related to one another.
And Sal has a lot of
videos that go through that
and can help you build that understanding.
But once you have that understanding,
these equations are kind of
like using a calculator where
they help you save time.
It's important to
know how to add, subtract,
to multiply and divide,
so you know what a calculator
is doing when you use it.
But once you understand that,
the calculator is a really valuable tool.
And that's what these equations are like,
they're tools that we can
use when we understand
where they come from.
With that out of the way, let's
dive into our example here.
So the question says,
"A light rail commuter train
"accelerates at a rate of 1.35
meters per second squared.
"How long does it take
to reach its top speed
"of 80 kilometers per
hour starting from rest?"
All right, so let's unpack
this and see what it's saying.
So let's just start at the beginning.
A light rail commuter train accelerates
at a rate of 1.35 meters
per second squared.
So that's pretty direct,
it's just telling us
what the acceleration is.
So let's write that down.
The acceleration is 1.35
meters per second squared.
All right, there's one thing.
Okay, so let's keep going.
How long does it take
to reach its top speed
of 80 kilometers per
hour starting from rest?
So that one's a little
bit more complicated,
there's more going on in here.
But if we just start at
the beginning and say,
"How long does it take?"
That by itself is a question.
There's some more stuff afterward,
but that by itself is just
asking about the time,
how long does it take?
All right, so let's note that
by circling this time here.
We don't know what it is yet,
but this is our question,
we're being asked about the time.
All right, so if we keep going here,
we get, all right,
how long does it take
to reach its top speed
of 80 kilometers per hour?
That's saying its top speed
is 80 kilometers per hour.
When it's done speeding up,
it'll be going at 80 kilometers per hour.
So that's the final velocity
or just our velocity at the time here.
So that's 80 kilometers per hour.
80.0 kilometers per hour.
And sometimes you'll see this
right here written as V sub f
to really explicitly say
it's the final velocity.
So the notation might vary
in your physics class.
Whatever notation you use, that's fine,
but make sure to ask
yourself what is this symbol
really talking about.
So anyway, 80 kilometers per hour,
per hour.
Okay.
And so we have that.
And then if we keep going,
it says, "Starting from rest."
So that's saying that at the
beginning when it starts,
it's at rest, which means it has
zero for it's initial velocity,
it's just sitting there.
So let's fill that in,
that's zero meters per second.
Okay.
So we had analyzed this question
and we see that, actually,
the change in distance didn't appear
anywhere in this question,
it's just these four values right here.
So let's see if we can
look at these equations
and identify one that
has all of these things
and doesn't have delta x,
since we don't know delta x
and we're not looking for it either.
So we see these two have delta x here
so we can rule those out.
And this one also has a delta
x so we can rule that out.
So that leaves this one.
Let's see, it has velocity,
the final velocity here,
it has the initial velocity here,
it has acceleration here,
and then it also has time which
is what we're looking for.
So we can use this.
We've figured out that for
this question right here,
we can just use that top equation.
All right, and then to continue this
we would plug in numbers
and then solve for t
and see what that time indeed is.
So for this video,
we're not going to have
to go through that,
we're just going to go through another
example of setting things up.
So let's go down to this
question right here.
While entering a freeway,
a car accelerates from rest
at a rate of 2.40 meters
per second squared
for 12.0 seconds.
How far does the car travel
during those 12 seconds
and what is the car's final velocity?
So this one actually asks two questions.
Let's just focus on the
first one to begin with,
and also let's see what we know.
So while entering a freeway,
a car accelerates from rest
at a rate of 2.40 meter
per second for 12 seconds.
So there's a lot of information
here in this first sentence.
So let's see, it says,
"Accelerates from rest," right
here, accelerates from rest.
That tells us that the initial
velocity is zero, right?
From rest, it wasn't moving initially,
it was at rest.
So let's write that down.
This also, just like the previous example,
had an initial velocity
of zero meters per second.
That's not always the case,
but it happens that in
these two examples it was.
So let's keep going.
So it accelerates from rest
at a rate of 2.40 meters
per second squared.
So that's telling us
what the acceleration is,
2.40 meters per second squared.
So let's write that down, 2.40
meters per second squared,
meters per second squared.
And in all of these problems,
it's important to think about
whether something is moving
in the positive direction
or in the negative direction
or if it's accelerating
in the positive direction
or the negative direction.
It actually looks like for these examples
we've chosen everything is
moving in the positive direction
and accelerating in that same direction.
So we won't have any
negative signs pop up,
but it is important to think about that
when you're doing these kinds of things,
just in case something is negative
and that does affect your
answer and what's going on.
But anyway, so it's accelerating forward,
everything is going in the same direction.
So we're thinking of the forward
as the positive direction
and they're accelerating, this car,
is accelerating at 2.40
meters per second squared.
All right, and it says also
that it's doing that for 12.0 seconds.
So we can write that down as well,
12.0 seconds.
All right, so we know three things here.
And you'll find that
in problems like this,
that's the magic number.
Once you have three of these,
you can find out the other
pieces using these equations.
Anyway, so the first question says,
"How far does the car travel
during those 12.0 seconds?"
Well, it's asking how far,
so that's going to be the delta x here,
this change in position.
How far does it travel
during those 12 seconds?
It's going to be this value right here.
So this is our question,
circle it here.
So now notice we don't have this,
so we can look for an
equation that doesn't have
this final velocity value in it
and then that will be an equation that
will hopefully have these other four,
but we'll have to check that.
This one has that final velocity in it,
so we can rule that out.
I see this one also
has the final velocity.
This one doesn't have the final velocity.
So let's look at that.
So it has the position,
the change in position,
that's what we're looking
for, it has it right there.
The initial velocity is right here,
so we have that as well.
Let's see, it has time
in it and we have time,
so we will be able to plug that in.
And then finally, it
also has acceleration.
So it has everything we need,
it has the thing we're looking for,
and it doesn't include anything
that we just don't know,
that we're not even looking for.
So we found that for
this problem right here.
This second equation here is going to be
the one that is most useful
for answering the question,
"How far does the car travel
during those 12 seconds?"
So that's for that question,
but this block here
actually has a second question.
Maybe I'll switch to green.
Let's look at this question.
What is the car's final velocity?
All right, so that means
we're looking for this now.
Right here, what's this?
Well, we've already identified
these different pieces that we know,
and if we did the first
part of the problem,
we would actually have a
value for delta x here.
But assuming we didn't find that yet,
we could look at this and say,
"What's the car's final velocity?
"I want to look for
something that has V in it
"and has these other
three things that I know."
And if you look and
you check through here,
let's see, what is it?
So, yeah, it would actually
end up being this one again.
This is that equation that doesn't have
the change in position in it.
And so just using the green color,
I'll underline this here to say that
this equation is useful for this question.
And actually, now that we have this value,
we could've used really any
of them that had our V in it.
So our options open up
once we know more than
three different things.
But anyway, hopefully going through
a couple of these examples
will be helpful for you when
you run into your own questions
and have to think through,
"Okay, what do I have,
"What am I looking for,
"and which equation will help me
"move forward and solve this question?"